so your book is called very fat very
brave and I think I'm kind of aware
where the title comes from because I'm a
fan of yours but for everybody that it
doesn't know why did you why did you
title it that so when a fat woman posts
on the internet like I picture
themselves in a bikini or something
revealing the internet goes my god
you're so brave fully insane thing to be
like somebody who'd bring a bathing suit
to go swimming is brave no they're just
wearing the correct articles of clothing
to do an activity and it's almost
insulting believe me look I always loved
that and they're like oh you're so
confident you just don't care and I'm
like what you don't care cuz I'm like I
spent hours it's like I care about
things maybe just not things that you
find important but I was like let's not
write me off like that like yeah it's
funny how they they're like oh you're
still confident I'm like I'm not
confident I'm just like being yes yes no
frustrating so he's very tongue-in-cheek
I don't think I'm actually brave but
like I would love to meet somebody who
was like worried for being in a bikini
like I want to meet that person to be
like I would have coffee with that
person well in the book you have a way
of dealing with haters and I want you to
tell everybody what that is oh I have so
many different ways I have a particular
favorite but I like whenever you say
that because this is my thing I always
say I think that's why I relate to it
I'm like do you have that much time to
sit at home yeah and like rail on me
right now like you like I don't even
know you you could have just ignored it
I'm like well I want your life if you
have that kind of time like you turn on
and go I'm sorry your life is so little
that you bet you're worried about me
over here like yeah I I like that one
too another one I have is if someone
calls you a cow you just turn around and
move with them I love that subscribe to
my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going